Jigsaw’s infamous bathroom game didn’t
play out quite like he drew it up in his plans.
To hear about the key detail that could have
changed everything, stick around to the end
of this video.
This video is sponsored by The CZsWorld Merch
Store.
Welcome to another episode of Things You Missed.
This week, I want to play a game.
So we’ll be covering the first major motion
picture from James Wan.
I feel like I’ve talked a lot about Wan’s
work a lot on the channel, and I have talked
about his franchises before, but this is actually
the first time I’ve done a Things You Missed
specifically on a film he directed.
So the clock is ticking, let’s let the game
begin.
The first item of note comes in before the
movie even starts, when we see the Twisted
Pictures logo animation.
The company was started in order to produce
Saw, and the intro is inspired by the Razor
Wire Trap, which is the second trap in the
movie, where a man named Paul is asked to
climb out of a cage riddled with barbed wire
and cut himself in order to escape.
The movie itself opens by showing us a little
light floating around the bathtub.
We don’t know what it is yet, but if you
look very closely it’s attached to the key
to Adam’s shackle, which goes down the drain
that opens when he wakes up in a panic.
In Saw III, we find out that it was Amanda
who placed the key there, and I think she
was supposed to put it somewhere else to give
Adam a chance to get it.
This means the game was designed with the
possibility of Adam being able to walk freely
around the bathroom, and there is more evidence
of this later on.
Dr. Gordon is already awake at the beginning
of the movie, and he demonstrates the reason
that Jigsaw has tested him, his lack of passion
for life, in his opening dialogue.
“You’re not dead.”
“Who’s that?”
“There’s no point in yelling.
I already tried...”
He sounds defeated.
He sounds like he doesn’t care if he lives
or dies.
The goal of Jigsaw’s game was basically
to change that, to enlighten these prisoners
on the joys of life.
To symbolize this enlightenment, we see a
big booming shot of the overhead lights literally
turning on above them.
This would also allow the glow-in-the-dark
paint to begin to charge.
The bathroom itself is very strange.
It’s a dilapidated men’s room, but with
no dividers.
It looks commercial; there are multiple toilets,
sinks and showers, so the inclusion of a bathtub
is strange.
I think the bathtub represents Jigsaw’s
idea of rebirth.
Adam awakes from it and is thrust into the
cold reality of the bathroom, just as we are
born from the womb into the harsh actuality
of our world.
We later learn that the bathroom is located
in a tunnel network underground.
John was once an engineer for low-income living
solutions, so I wonder if the bathroom was
once a part of some kind of communal shelter.
However, the sign seen in the tunnels at the
end of the movie says CAUTION: Raw Sewage.
So perhaps the bathroom was connected to some
kind of sewage treatment center.
When Adam first noticed John hiding in plain
sight, PRETENDING to be dead, he ironically
makes an observation.
“First dead body I’ve ever seen.
Different in real life.
They don’t move.”
...which is a nice touch considering what
happens in the final scene and really adds
to Adam’s sense of terror.
After beginning to solve the clues of the
game, Adam obtains the tape recorder and puts
in his tape.
“If anyone ever uses the excuse it’s just
a game, I’m gonna lose my mind.
I’m gonna lose it, like are you kidding
me?
You’re so stupid.
If anyone that ever uses the excuse that it’s
just a game, is a horrible human being.
And is lazy.”
“I don’t get it.”
There is a little clue left on Dr. Gordon’s
tape about the identity of Jigsaw.
Let’s roll that clip.
“...thing left to do is shoot yourself.”
*coughing*
(This is why we have to have social distancing.)
The coughing alludes to the fact that Gordon
already knows the killer, or he would if he
had taken more time to appreciate the human
side of his dying patients.
“His name is John,
Dr. Gordon.
He’s a very interesting person.”
The other clue whispered at the end of the
tape, “follow your heart”, leads Adam
to find the hacksaws.
As the audience, we can see that there is
something else in the bag (the photos Adam
had taken of Dr. Gordon) but Gordon himself
cannot see them.
Gordon eventually realizes that he and Adam
may have been placed in the bathroom by Jigsaw,
the unknown serial killer that Dr. Gordon
was once a suspect for.
The cops who questioned him are Stephen Sing
and David Tapp, and we see a flashback of
their first encounters at Jigsaw crime scenes.
They are introduced to the remains of Paul
by Alison Kerry.
One thing I found interesting is that her
badge says she’s the Deputy Coroner.
In Saw 2, she’s a Homicide Detective for
the newly formed serial killer task force,
so that tells me that the loss of Detectives
Sing and Tapp resulted in her getting a promotion.
There is also some important information on
the evidence bag telling us the date that
Paul was found was March 19th 2004.
This is shortly before a 6 month timeskip,
which lands the date of the bathroom game
somewhere in October of 2004, which is also
when Saw was released.
We’re first introduced to who John Kramer
is in Gordon’s flashback at the hospital,
and John has openly displayed his design sketch
for the reverse bear trap on the table.
Just like for anyone to see while he’s asleep
I guess.
If you’re gonna become a serial killer,
maybe don’t do that.
Just a suggestion.
But if you do, you might want to hide the
evidence just a little bit.
There’s a green X on the opposite page perhaps
symbolic of the X marks the spot from the
bathroom game.
Gordon ends up being cleared as a suspect,
but sticks around to hear the testimony of
the first survivor, Amanda, who tells the
story of how she woke up in a room and a tape
started playing.
“Hello Amanda.”
The upcoming ninth Saw movie is called Spiral,
and the name draws inspiration from the spirals
on the cheeks of Billy the Puppet and later,
the large spiral seen in John’s workshop
at the mannequin factory.
The spiraling camera movement when John is
first shown on screen, you know, the one where
he’s PRETENDING to be dead, could also be
a connection.
In my Spiral trailer analysis I talked about
how I think the Spiral could be kind of like
a new religious icon that John is inventing,
but I guess we’ll find out when the movie
comes out.
When Amanda goes to try to retrieve the key
to reverse bear trap, there’s a secret message
from Jigsaw hidden on the wall.
If you pause at just the right moment, you
can read it.
The message on the wall in Amanda’s cell
reads:
If you try to
keep your life for
yourself.
You will
lose it.
But if you can give
your life to me you will
find true life.
This message doesn’t seem to apply to Amanda,
but it may have been a part of a previous
game for the man described as being her cellmate,
Donnie Greco.
Donnie doesn’t seem to have much of a chance
to survive, he is essentially neutralized
while Amanda is forced to cut through his
stomach in order to retrieve her key.
But Jigsaw always believes in giving his victims
a second chance.
So I think Donnie already lost his game, and
his punishment was that he would now die in
Amanda’s game.
This message was probably part of the rules
for Donnie’s first game.
When Amanda cuts open his stomach, the camera
cuts to a shadow on the wall, a reference
to a technique seen in early German expressionism
films, like one of the earliest influential
horror movies ever, Nosferatu.
I should also note that many of the stylish
techniques used in Nosferatu were done to
save money, as Germany was still picking up
the pieces from World War 1 at the time it
was made.
Saw was also made for a very low budget, but
rather than picking up the pieces from World
War 1, the producers of Saw were picking up
the pieces of a second mortgage that they
had to put on their production headquarters,
and luckily for them, Saw ended up being very
successful and spawning many sequels.
While those sequels may not have been planned
from the beginning, I’d still like to point
out something I found interesting about Lawrence
Gordon’s home.
This will contain spoilers for the series,
so skip ahead 20 seconds if you haven’t
seen the rest of the movies.
Gordon has this clock in his living room,
with these little ornaments that look vaguely
like Jigsaw puzzle pieces.
This gear could also represent the idea of
mechanical engineering.
As you may know, Jigsaw was once a civil engineer.
And I like to think that these could be little
clues that Lawrence Gordon would one day make
the perfect successor to Jigsaw.
There are clocks all over Gordon’s house,
including both an hourglass and analog clock
on his desk, and that all ties into part of
the reason behind Jigsaw’s work: time.
All of this starts when John finds out from
Dr. Gordon how much time he has to live.
When he learns that, he learns how valuable
his time on this earth really is.
Back in the present, at the bathroom, Dr.
Gordon tells Adam about his favorite picture
of his family, which all three of them are
in, rare because someone usually has to take
the photo.
The shot is missing from his wallet, but I
think we actually do see it in his living
room if you pause during the chase at the
end of the movie.
I mean, it makes sense considering that this
family seems to just keep reusing the same
few photos all over the place.
Over and over.
And OVER!
The next flashback shows Gordon putting his
daughter to bed, and he tries to calm her
fears by doing the “This Little Piggy”
nursery rhyme with her.
In John Kramer’s MO, pigs represent rebirth,
that’s why all of his followers don the
pig masks when carrying out tasks for Jigsaw.
After he leaves, his daughter sees Zep hiding
in the closet, in what almost certainly seems
to be an homage to that scene from Black Christmas.
Roll it.
“Agnes…
Agnes…”
“Huh?”
Meanwhile, Detective Tapp has been unable
to accept Lawrence Gordon’s innocence even
after the doctor provides an alibi, and spies
on him from a messy apartment across the way.
What I cannot answer is why Detective Tapp
has Amy’s coffee though.
What have you done to Amy, Detective Tapp?
“What did you do to them you bastard?”
Yeah, the apartment is a mess, and the walls
are covered in reconnaissance photos of the
doctor and newspaper headlines about the Jigsaw
murders.
Surprisingly, none of the names or authors
mentioned in these articles are easter eggs
or references to anything.
There is one connection that would be made
retro-actively, when Saw: The Video Game was
released in 2009.
The author of this article is Oswald McGillicutty,
a name that was given to the journalist character
you save in the game, although the game is
not considered canon.
The actual contents of the article, as we
often see in movies, have nothing to do with
the headline.
This one is about a toy called Goofy Clay
that exploded and destroyed a trailer home
in Reno.
The only other semi-interesting tidbit I found
in these headlines was this article, which
references Stanley Kubrick’s 2001 A Space
Odyssey, which doesn’t really have anything
to do with Saw, but is just a well respected
movie in general.
There would be a more meaningful reference
shortly after, when Sing and Tapp discover
the location of Jigsaw’s hideout.
The map they use doesn’t seem to correlate
to any real world locations that I could find
on Google Maps, but they end up determining
that the fire alarm heard in the tape must
have been from an emergency at 213 Stygian
Street.
Stygian Street is a reference to James Wan’s
first independent film, Stygian, and the address
number 213 is a reference to the area code
of Lacy Production Center, where Saw was filmed.
When they arrived there the workshop contained
a miniature version of The Bathroom, but Dr.
Gordon’s shackle is replaced with an electrical
wire which is connected to this battery.
This is perhaps our first clue about the electric
shock component connected to each of their
chains.
Jigsaw first used this on Adam, to ensure
he wasn’t cheating,
then on Gordon
to try to snap him out of his miserable wallowing,
then again on Adam to make him drop
the gun he was holding,
and then on the
audience, because the ending was a shocking
twist...
yeah, ok I’ll go off myself for
that pun.
John’s workshop also provided another clue
about the true method that Adam could have
used to win and survive the bathroom game.
The reason that the miniature version of the
bathroom contains figures to represent Gordon
and Jigsaw but not Adam could be because when
we see this, it’s still 6 months before
the game takes place, and Adam had not yet
been hired to photograph Gordon, and so, was
not yet a target of John Kramer.
However, it’s clear that the game only works
with a second player, so I think the fact
that we don’t see Adam in this diagram,
is because of what I mentioned near the beginning
of this video.
Adam was supposed to have an opportunity to
retrieve his key and have the ability to free
roam around the bathroom and possibly escape.
I’m not saying he definitely was supposed
to get out of his shackle, otherwise why bother
with the whole electric shock component, but
it seems like freedom to move about may have
been something Adam could have earned.
Also, this may have been the same miniature
used by the set designers of the movie when
they created the actual bathroom, because
it actually says Saw Bathroom Set right here.
Guess we can call this James Wan’s coffee
cup moment.
Zep watches the game unfold from a little
area setup within Gordon’s home.
I noticed there is a microphone there, which
made me wonder if there was ever supposed
to be an aspect of the game where Zep communicates
with them directly.
Or maybe Zep was just planning on starting
a little podcast, “The Jigsaw Victim Podcast”.
Let’s see you ****ing top that Bobby Dagen!
Zep watches as Gordon discovers the hidden
box containing the phone causing him to remember
night he was captured, and every time I watch
it it makes me ****ing crazy.
I mean, why would Adam, who is trying to SECRETLY
spy on Dr. Gordon use the flash while taking
photos of him?
I mean, that makes no sense.
That’s just the dumbest thing I’ve ever
seen.
I’m sorry, I’m sorry.
But you’re an idiot Adam.
You’re an idiot.
“You know who I am.”
Lawrence becomes more suspicious of Adam’s
secrets, and rightfully so, and asks what
else he may be hiding.
“Well let’s see.
On my sixth birthday, my best friend at the
time, Scott Tibbs, stabbed me with a rusty
nail, I didn’t tell you about that.”
On the DVD for Saw II, there is a bonus video
called The Scott Tibbs Documentary which is
a found footage short created by Scott.
“I had to find out more!
So I acquired this sweet little camera, and
I’m making my own documentary about this
sick ****er!
Scott Tibbs style baby!”
Yeah, it’s not very good.
OK, it’s kind of one of the most embarrassing
things I’ve seen a professional film studio
put out, and it’s considered to be non-canon
to the Saw story, but I did want to bring
it up because the character Scott himself
is still canon, and there will be more references
to him in future Things You Missed episodes.
When it comes down to the end of the game,
Lawrence finally caves in, saws off his foot,
gets the bullet and the gun... but decides
to try the play dead trick with Adam one last
time.
This attempt was a little bit smarter because
it didn’t require any… acting ability
on Adam’s part.
We all know how that turned out last time.
I think Lawrence gives the signal when the
camera cuts to the back of his head right
here, where he probably winks at Adam.
The play dead trick also calls back to earlier
in the film, where Jigsaw does the same thing
to trick Sing.
It ends up being used many times throughout
the Saw franchise, so I’ll be sure to point
those out in future episodes of Things You
Missed.
The movie ends with Gordon passing the test
and Adam failing to achieve his enlightenment,
and as a result, Jigsaw locks him away in
the dark.
“Game over.”
...but unlike all of the sports leagues right
now, there would be games to look forward
to in the future, and I’m gonna be covering
them right here on CZsWorld.
Join me next week for my first Saw episode
of Horror History, and the next episode of
Things You Missed where I’ll be covering
my personal favorite film in Saw franchise,
Saw II.
If you love Saw, you won’t want to miss
out on any of this stuff, so make sure you
subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every
week, RING that deathell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.